ça fait déjà 5 ans qu'on utilise un dice
un dispositif de consignation
électronique
dans le milieu on appelle cela un
lookbook électronique il y a personne
qui peut tricher maintenant tout le
monde doit respecter son amplitude de
conduire
l'appareil est connecté au moteur du
véhicule et enregistre à la fois les
heures conduites et les heures de repos
du conducteur si par exemple le
chauffeur passe plus de 13h consécutives
sur la route soit le maximum d'heures
permise au Québec il reçoit
automatiquement un message d'alerte et
doit s'immobiliser c'est dans le trafic
sur mon infraction tu as une période de
grâce si il y a une tempête de neige
tombe en infraction est une période de
grâce mais dès que tu tombes en
infraction il y a un pop-up qui sort
dans le système
des objectifs du logbook électronique
ces deux prévenir les accidents liés à
la fatigue
on dormait le temps qu'on voulait bien
dormir on partait on pouvait peut-être
sauver jusqu'à 24 heures dans une
semaine et même plus dans certains cas
là on fera les heures auxquelles on
exposait faire entre 2016 et 2021 le
nombre d'accidents mortels et d'accident
grave impliquant un camion lourd abondit
de plus de 6%
aussi que notre force de travail est des
outils pour se protéger et celui-là en
est un c'est une protection aussi pour
l'employé pour le chauffeur pour le
camion et c'est aussi une protection
contre toute forme de compétition
déloyale aussi aux États-Unis le log
électronique est obligatoire depuis
décembre 2019 donc les camionnettes du
Québec qui font l'aller-retour entre le
Canada et les États-Unis n'avaient pas
le choix de s'en procurer un au Canada
la majorité des provinces ont déjà
emboîté le pas à côté du premier janvier
de cette année et son imposition au
Québec était d'ailleurs très attendue
par les membres de l'industrie ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada MONT